to go back to the point where we bring
up that brought us into that
conversation is newsmax
so when fox news cr let me start with
this chris evans posted this clip
famous captain america sevens and it's
john roberts saying
trump's campaign has said not all legal
votes have been cast
are counted and not all illegal votes
have been excluded
where they're coming up short is
evidence and like our evidence of fraud
or whatever and then chris evans starts
laughing like
like did you google search it because
that's not true john roberts was not
reporting the truth
because the lawsuit's from trump and
there's another thing they do i can't
remember uh
which i was watching cnn reality check
they said in trump's lawsuit
they come out and admit there's no voter
fraud and then they show a highlight on
the v
on the forms and they don't highlight
the portion where it says
we are arguing about 529 ballot
irregularities
and then the judge says so you're not
arguing fraud not to my knowledge here
sir
they weren't saying there was no fraud
period it was one lawsuit about 500
ballots the judge said
are you implying there's fraud on these
bouts no these are about improperly
filled out ballots
they took that clip factual but not
truthful to manipulate people so
in terms of fox news you've got regular
people who are like i
literally watched a video of this thing
happen and fox news said it didn't
happen
later and they go to newsmax or they go
to oan newsmax seems to do a fairly good
job though they are extremely biased but
i'll tell you my favorite part of all of
this
is we hear what what barack obama is
saying about the internet right
brian stelter of cnn said it's a threat
to our democracy
that people that conservatives are going
to newsmax and parlor because they're
not being
kept in the confines of the ivory
cathedral
uh it's our democracy always means do
what we want
it's all it's interesting that phrase is
uh getting such
it's such a begging the question kind of
thing assuming that what you're trying
to prove
when you use that our democracy you do
not regard the people
who view things differently than you as
part of your democracy
you view them as illegitimate deplorable
evil
ugly chumps yeah
ugly ugly chumps well he's not awfully
wrong
i get real triggered when they say the
american people
whenever someone says that and tries to
talk about 350 million of us like they
know what we're thinking
drives me insane no they don't they
don't yeah they don't care about
people and it's it's you know maybe a
long time ago the inception of this
country
it made sense when a congress a
congressperson would represent
back then congressman would represent 30
000 people
now with 750 000 all they're doing
especially in senate races
and for federal federal elections
they're going they look at
numbers raw numbers the ratings it's not
about the individuals and what they need
is about the ratings
so they're looking at this the same as
like a tv show i was looking at how did
we do in last night's debate do we score
good in the ratings
and what they like i'm using an analogy
but it's basically how many people
liked the show that's it i don't think
it's that's
i think it's more nefarious than that i
think a lot like for example when chris
wallace
is moderating debate between donald
trump and joe biden
and he explicitly says when they're
trying to teach critical race
theory and he calls it all their
teachers all their teaching is not to be
rude to someone who's an immigrant he
didn't
he didn't even say critical race theory
he said trump you recently banned
sensitivity training yes
and then i was like what no he didn't
did you even read it that's not what he
meant and also
to categorize it in that specific way
let's that's a valid point of view
it's not your place to uh
qualified and say this is what it means
but let each candidate say their point
of view
especially if someone banned it why did
you ban it explain to me
right that wasn't a debate it was it was
literally just
set up against donald trump and what i
think what's interesting is fox which
has i think by far the most loyal
audience of all the networks i think the
average fox year watches like 12 hours a
day
they are feeling really uh um
betrayed that the fox the fox isn't
acting
like people who watch cnn thinks fox
acts yeah chris wallace and megan kelly
in 2020 in 2016
were by far the hardest moderators on
donald trump yeah
and now you've it's really funny because
the left keeps saying like whenever fox
says something that's bad for trump they
go wow even fox news is
saying it even mitt romney voted right
yeah yeah mitt romney
we all think he's you know bastion of
conservatism
corporate politicians who who pretend to
represent the people
and we're supposed to be surprised but
i'll tell you what's crazy is
do like regular people are being snapped
out of this and it's like a cascade
effect
i guess you call it a white pill like
what is that that's the red pill the
white pill is the hope but yeah the red
that's what i mean i mean the white pill
like from seeing other people wake up
it's that there's a path to victory
exactly we thought here's the definition
of the white pill hold on i wrote it
down last time i was here because i want
to get the wording exactly
i have the documents he does from the
allies
knock knock who's there sandy sandy who
didn't you get enough trouble with that
alex
this is the white pill this is the
official definition you internet nerds
it's possible we will lose it's
it's it's impossible that we must lose
that's all you need and now increasingly
people are just saying
i'm sick of it because in 2008 as i
tweeted out
barack obama used the internet to get
elected data mining in 2012
they were all fellating him so excited
this guy's the greatest thing ever
he used facebook leverage thing and now
that they
it goes the other way the internet's the
biggest threat to our democracy
you don't have to have a view on obama
or on the internet to be like
someone is not keeping their story
straight it's like a husband is cheating
on you
at a certain point you're like these
stories just don't add up i don't
believe you
you know what's weird this show has some
kind of like
barrier don't ask me why it's the beanie
we had on alex's channel
no it's the tinfoil hat that's the
barrier not only did we have on
alex jones with michael uh-huh the show
got pulled
by youtube nobody wrote about it just
the washington cognitive dissonance
what is people are unable to qualify
it's like
it's like what do they write about it
de-verify they write about joe rogan all
the time no they don't know where to
if they start to accept some of the
things we talk about or some things it
will it will
viscerate their their world view so
they're in their mind it's like
incapable it's what they call cognitive
this is this is the point i made like
the last four years what if
instead of trump being literally hitler
he's just like a jerk what if he's like
a mediocre like william mckinley
president right
but if he's just like mediocre and like
a c-minus
the whole story falls apart right
because then it's like why am i supposed
to be upset because guys it kind of
sucks
you know but it has to be that he's the
worst existential threat of america's
ever had so
it's like they don't know how to deal
with things that don't fit into their
convenient packaging
it's a it's a complicated system like
for for the uh for
not i don't like saying the average
person because i can't speak for other
people but
just trying to learn about the world
economic forum and things outside of the
global
you know the american government even
the american government itself is super
complex so like to
say like president's pretty average kind
of c-minus
d-plus maybe yeah i agree with you well
i don't think you were actually saying
about trump
no but i'm not saying if you're just
going to that point
because we all know he's like a plus
plus s-class he's the best
plus he's a very stable genius yes
indeed
which is more than obvious so you agree
he's not the villain if you were to go
this route he's not the villain you know
what he's going to say
so he's going to say i accomplished
everything i wanted to in four years
so i didn't need a second character oh
snap you're right
i think you might be right and then
he'll say i never lost it was stolen
he'll never admit defeat or i mean we're
looking at some
goings-on and maybe he's just like i won
i won the whole time
listen this wouldn't be the first time a
cop stole something okay that's fair
yeah civil asset forfeiture yeah yeah
there you go
um did you guys hear jack dorsey uh
testified
it's a waste of time it's a waste of
time he actually said that centralized
adjudication of social networks is not
scalable
jack dorsey has been whispering sweet
nothings into the ears of everyone for
the past several years
and i sat in front of him and he said
all of the same things he's repeated
over and over again and he is lying he's
saying that every time he's lying or
delusional
he's lying i think he's saying that's
inaccurate so he said
we want to have a path to redemption two
years ago he's been saying we don't have
bias
years ago i explained to him how his
bias exists in the rules and he still
feigns ignorance
there's no way at this point he's like i
didn't realize that i don't think he
owns it you don't know that though
it could be people's brains are
complicated things i'm just playing
devil's advocate
it could be that when you say things
that don't port into his larger world
view
he literally can't process it i've dm'd
with him okay
no for sure i think it's like every
single time something bad happens it's
really obvious
he goes there was a mistake and we're
fixing it and it's like oh it's a
mistake
you know there was a poll that came out
there's actually two polls showing that
when people learned of hunter biden's
scandal
they regretted voting for biden oh wow
and they said the percentage point was
like five or six percent which clearly
would have given trump the victory if
people had known
the media kept this a a secret social
media
banned the information because they are
trying to help
they want to help joe biden win these
look i think it's indisputable at this
point
because they didn't ban trump's tax
returns they didn't ban the leak tapes
of melania
they didn't ban the edward snowden leaks
this was i think ted cruz brought this
up maybe was head cruise
did you ban the edward snowden what
about julie swetnick
with kavanaugh yeah well so that wasn't
hacked information though right
the argument was well we only banned
this because
we presumed the information was hacked
and we made a mistake but
what about the pentagon papers this was
there this is their big thing it's like
this is
secret government information this is
the new york times at its finest it's
obviously a lie
it's obviously a lie so when they were
asked about trump's tax returns he said
well they were reporting on them not
giving out the documents or whatever
it's like okay well
what about the the leaked melania tapes
where money was secretly recorded
well that's not hacking you know what
dude they look
oh good what about mary trump her book
she re this is i thought
look i it was information no no but mary
trump secretly quoted her aunt who's a
judge or a retired judge
and the aunt was saying horrible things
about her brother donald then it's just
like you
you reported that perfectly fine so the
the point is
twitter makes up this new excuse if it's
hacked information we won't allow it
even though it wasn't but they're using
an excuse it's easy for them to
always have an excuse for why they are
subverting
our commons our our ability to to
uh to vote our institutions there's
always an excuse this says from the new
york times this is that
dorsey only owns two percent of twitter
now so i don't think he has like no
power i think he's a figurehead he gave
it up yeah so when he said so he's just
saying all of these things that have
nothing to do and he has no power to
change it anymore like probably yeah so
but he did
acknowledge that centralized
adjudication basically what he was
saying is that
um a company trying to be the arbiter of
what can come and go and be banned
is is not scalable it's not you have to
have self-reporting and things like that
yeah it's the data is not it's
impossible and that i think obama was
kind of
it goes along with what obama was saying
about the danger of these
social media companies controlling the
narrative but what i don't think they
appreciate just from
and maybe this is going to be concern
trolling i don't know but like in the
90s when you had the project i figured
what was called
tipper gore was involved in a few other
people and they were saying what there's
all these songs in the radio that were
like a problem and you can't have a
cindy lauper shebop was one of the songs
that they were trying to get banned
because it's about pleasuring yourself
apparently
so their solution was okay yeah i don't
know i think madonna was also on that
list
uh the solution was when you have a cd
in the in the store
to have a big warning label it contains
explicit lyrics well that's how you know
what the good cds are
right yeah so it's kind of thing where
it's like oh this is misinformation
that's like planting a flag encouraging
people to look into it
yeah there's a bunch of memes now going
around where people will say something
and then put a misinformation
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time